eine studie der eu-kommission hat
ergeben die deutschen gehören zu den
unzufriedensten bahnkunden europas
sowieso immer zu spät oder selten
pünktlich ist lange wartezeiten
überfüllte züge schmutzige toiletten die
reisenden sind wütend es ist echt
grausam was die gene angeht
pünktlichkeit angeht ticketkauf es ist
einfach nur noch schrecklich es ist die
geschichte einer enttäuschten liebe
nicht einmal enttäuscht sondern immer
und immer wieder jahrzehntelang und
dabei hat dieser sommer der neuen euro
tickets gezeigt wie viele millionen
menschen sich für die bahn entschieden
haben oder entscheiden würden wenn preis
und service stimmt dieses millionenfache
ja zur bahn aber hat deren probleme nur
noch deutlicher offengelegt
vollgestopfte personenzüge verspätungen
wie lange nicht und stehen die güterzüge
wegen schienennetz überlastung dazu
immer neue oft kleinteilige baustellen
die für stau auf den gleisen sorgen
wieso aber ist die bahn überhaupt in
einer so misslichen lage und wie
realistisch ist es dass sich der eher
jammervollen zustand zügig beheben lässt
das setzen wir heute für sie in den
kontext herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
zumindest die politische ampelschaltung
ist für die bahn eindeutig der
koalitionsvertrag sieht vor dass sich
innerhalb von acht jahren die zahl der
menschen die fernverkehrszüge nutzt
verdoppeln soll man muss kein prophet
sein um zu sehen wie ambitioniert dieses
ziel ist denn vor allem drei zentrale
probleme gilt es auf diesem weg zu lösen
erstes problem verspätungen und
zugausfälle die bahn kommt aber wann
ganz ähnlich wie in dem werbespot fragt
sich das auch so mancher kunde auf
deutschlands bahnhöfen
bei uns kommt die leute waren immer zu
spät im juni dieses jahres kamen 42
prozent aller fernzüge nicht pünktlich
hauptgrund für die schlechte quote bei
der pünktlichkeit waren die vielen
baustellen noch nie wurde so viel am
schienennetz gebaut wie aktuell die bahn
leidet an einem massiven sanierungsstau
kommen wir zum zweiten großen problem
zum sehr überschaubaren komfort und auch
das bemängeln bahnkunden und
bahnkundinnen seit jahrzehnten freut
mich auch stört sie nicht nur die
verspätungen sondern der schrott der auf
der schiene schließende tür nicht gehen
nicht auf die züge sind überfüllt
ich habe ein kleines kind ist diese
schöne wie die studenten zu nutzen zum
beispiel lauter einen bericht aus 2018
weisen vier fünftel aller ec mängel auf
problem nummer drei die hohen preise
also ich bin die bahn ist eigentlich
schon teuer genug wenn ich in
deutschland möglichst den meisten klicks
günstiger ist also die bahn ist teuer zu
unkomfortabel zu unpünktlich und das
wiederum hat drei wesentliche ursachen
erstens es fehlt an einem ausreichend
guten schienennetz und da lohnt sich ein
kurzer rückblick nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg galt zwei staaten zwei bahnen
in der bundesrepublik gab es die
bundesbahn und in der ddr die reichsbahn
aber in beiden staaten werden der erhalt
und die modernisierung des
schienennetzes
vernachlässigt und die bahn auf
verschleiß gefahren
anfang der 1990 er jahre ist die
quittung unübersehbar die infrastruktur
ist veraltet und beide systeme sind hoch
verschuldet mit einem defizit von knapp
vier milliarden mark rund rund 41
milliarden mark schulden ist die
deutsche bundesbahn ins jahr 1989
eingefahren heilung verspricht man sich
von zwei maßnahmen fusion und
privatisierung db das hieß bisher
deutsche bundesbahn aber das ist vorbei
dgb heißt jetzt deutsche bahn in dieser
aktiengesellschaft ist auch die
ehemalige ddr reichsbahn aufgegangen
1999 wird hartmut meter und chef der
deutschen bahn und er stellt die weichen
richtung strikten sparkurs das heißt
auch dass wir keine
unternehmung mehr starten dürfen die
sich nicht rechnen und wir werden hier
mit spitzer feder rechnen und nur dinge
machen die mich wirklich rechnen dazu
gehörte es auch viele weichen und
schienen entfernen zu lassen denn die
sind teuer in der wartung meter uns
knallharter sparkurs allerdings wird von
der politik ausdrücklich unterstützt
experten kritisieren außerdem dass in
den vergangenen 20 jahren auch viele
weichen abgebaut wurden weil sie
weiteres intensiv und damit teuer sind
weiche bedeutet aber kapazität also wenn
vorher ein zug liegen bleibt oder ein
zug sehr langsam fährt kann ich denn
überholen wenn die weiche nicht mehr da
ist kann ich denen nicht überholt und
muss 20 kilometer hinter einem langsam
zug her grummeln und das bedeutet jede
störung zieht weitere störungen nach
sich schuld trägt übrigens auch das
eisenbahn gesetz das mit einer absurden
vorschrift zur absurden folgen führt
eine ursache ist zum beispiel die dass
die bahn bei reparaturen grundsätzlich
selbst zahlen muss wenn aber ein
kompletter neubau erfolgt dann springt
der bund ein und wenn ich unternehmer
wäre würde ich dann auch warten bis eine
brücke komplett zerstört ist weil dann
brauche ich nicht bezahlen in zukunft
will der bund nun die sanierung des
maroden schienennetzes vorantreiben die
generalsanierung soll
2024 starten schienen sind das eine
problem der bahn fehlt es aber auch an
personal meter und ließ während seines
sparkurses tausende arbeitsplätze
abbauen anfang 1994 hatte die bahn nach
eigenen angaben noch rund
350.000 beschäftigten die zahl wurde
seitdem fast halbiert eine bessere
planung eine starke schiene gibt es
nicht zum nulltarif das gilt für uns
genauso wie für den bund wir müssen
massiv in das system investieren auf
unserer seite personal und fahrzeuge nur
um einmal aktuell zu vergleichen die
hochgelobten schweizer eisenbahn sind
das nicht durch zufall der investitions
vergleich in das schienennetz allein des
vergangenen jahres ist erschüttert
deutschland investierte
124 euro pro bürger und bürgerinnen in
der schweiz waren es
413 euro und den luxemburg sogar
607 euro auch wenn die bundes
investitionen in die
schieneninfrastruktur in den vergangenen
jahren gestiegen sind liegt deutschland
im vergleich mit anderen europäischen
ländern noch immer auf einen der
hinteren plätze warum aber wird nicht
mehr getan um die beschriebenen und seit
jahren bestehenden probleme zu lösen die
antwort hat viel mit struktur zu tun
denn die deutsche bahn ag ist eine
aktiengesellschaft bei der der deutsche
staat eigentümer aller aktien ist die
bahn ist also ein privates unternehmen
in staatlichen besitz und steht damit in
einem ständigen spannungsverhältnis
zwischen dem konzern interesse geld zu
verdienen und dem gemeinwohl aller und
das problem im problem ist dass selbst
der bund als eigentümer das gemeinwohl
weniger im blick hatte als die eigene
kassenlage über viele jahre wurde nicht
genug investiert und die bahn
vernachlässigt eigentlich hat der
rechnungshof seit jahren ja darauf
hingewiesen dass die bahn in eine
zunehmende schieflage gerät die
bundesregierung hat es immer ignoriert
die fakten sind seit jahren bekannt aber
jetzt hat es also eine dramatik erreicht
in der man also eigentlich nicht mehr
weiter weg gucken kann nach der fusion
von bundes- und reichsbahn übernahm der
bund die altschulden beider systeme und
häufte in der folge immer weitere
schulden an inzwischen sind es rund 29
milliarden euro netto finanzschulden und
als wäre das nicht schon genug
zusätzlich hat die bahn ein problem der
fokussierung sie ist in über 130 ländern
aktiv hat extrem viele
tochterunternehmen das hiesige
gemeinwohl aber offensichtlich nicht
immer ausreichend im blick eine kritik
die seit jahren überhört wird die
deutsche bundesregierung die eigentlich
die waren zu 100 prozent kontrollieren
könnte aber nicht tut lässt die bahn
gewähren als wäre es ein global player
und finden es ganz toll sind dubai oder
in china oder usa und den firmen
aufkauft und sagt nichts wenn die preise
hier erhöht haben wenn die bahn nicht an
gewann gemeinwohl und nicht eine
menschliche bedürfnisse sich orientiert
diesen beitrag von 2012 über die
entwicklung der preise bei der bahn
finden sie in voller länge in unserer
mediathek die ampel koalition will nun
endlich alles heilen im juni kündigte
verkehrsminister volker wissing eine
generalsanierung an wir wollen eine
hochleistungsfähige deutsche bahn die
sicher und pünktlich die bürgerinnen und
bürger an ihre ziele bringen ein
hochleistungsnetz so bezeichnen sie es
heute soll entstehen und so der
zuständige minister die das netz
zuständige bahntochter soll in eine
gemeinwohlorientierte
gesellschaft überführt werden es geht um
mehr einfluss durch den bund aber
achtung eine hochleistungsfähige bahn
stand auch schon früher auf den
politisch verkündeten agenda ohne erfolg
wir brauchen eine stark aufgestellte
bahn im 21 jahrhundert und genau das tue
ich indem ich das ruder herum ziehe und
in zukunft eine bahnpolitik betreiber
die auf investitionen in die schiene und
auf investition in das rollende material
gerichtet ist die zwanziger jahre stehen
unter dem motto machen jetzt es wird das
jahrzehnt der schiene
die konsequenzen des jahrelangen
missmanagements werden sich leider nicht
kurzfristig beheben lassen und dabei
wäre eine leistungsfähige
nutzerfreundliche und pünktliche bahn
wichtiger denn je wir stecken mitten in
der klima- und energiekrise und wir
bürgerinnen und bürger scheinen doch
bereiter denn je mit der bahn zu fahren
insgesamt wurden ungefähr 40 millionen
euro tickets verkauft wie stehen sie zur
deutschen bahn welche erfahrungen haben
sie gemacht schreiben sie es mir gerne
in die kommentare
wenn sie mehr kontext sehen wollen hier
eine folge mit meiner kollegin aminata
belly die flutkatastrophe im aartal in
den kontext gesetzt hat und wenn sie
noch mehr über die deutsche bahn wissen
wollen dann empfehle ich ihnen dieses
video von meinen kolleginnen und
kollegen